[Music]
so gk is a managed kubernetes service
the fleet is where we manage the
kubernetes muster in nodes at scale for
you and it's where we invest lots of
time and thinking to abstract away the
complexity and variety of options the
framework offered to you so you can
focus on your workloads your business
application as you can probably know the
open source community is super engaged
it writes lots of code changes and
improvement and as you can see on this
slide I have some data here from
presentation that was even last year in
at cube con you can see the amount of
add-ons repositories and code changes
that we need to manage when we think
about managing kubernetes clusters for
you in the fleet our goal with GK is
actually streamline and simplify the
management for your for your cluster and
provide hassle-free service
this means non disruptive and continuous
service that support your business
through low and high demand periods or
seasons I guess there are different
market segments or market verticals that
I could use for example here but this
one evidently shows you the reliability
we deliver by gke to retailer customers
specifically doing a very high peak
season Black Friday in Cyber Monday
among these customers we have la blaw
which I mentioned before Canada's
largest retailer and I'm really excited
to have just in here and he will share
with you more about their experience
later in the session so next let's dive
into kind of the mechanics of managing a
fleet and what controls you have kate
here will walk you through some of live
demos and show you tools and
capabilities you can use today to manage
disruption and risk so basically my job
as an engineer on GJ infrastructure is
connect two-fold first ensure
ability for the product but also make
sure that it's easy to maintain and on
the intersection of those two different
dimensions is actually the upgrade story
because as you know we're on a fleet of
thousand clusters and one of interesting
aspect of running hosted kubernetes is
that their versions as you know we move
the master version regularly
however they upgrade of the notes is
under your customer control so how do we
deal with that situation because when
the gap between the control plane and
the client grows you might run into
incompatibility one solution here is to
have note out upgrades and we have such
a feature however rarely or not as often
as we would like people use it and why
is that because it's hard to give
control up and that is because upgrades
bring workload disruption and while we
try to manage that were called
disruption that is reality of it
upgrades bring disruption and even
though our fleet is different in shape
and sizes it's even harder to upgrade
smaller clusters smaller note Falls
because you don't have extra capacity
that can cover the disruption period so
what actually happens behind the scenes
when you upgrade a cluster node by node
we drain a node we recreate a VM we wait
for that VM to run to start to become
running and then we wait for the node to
be registered with the master and become
ready and then the workload is resumed
so this is the period where your
business it might experience some
disruption how can we make this better
well if you look at that timeline you
can see that there are certain things
that we can move out from the
rescheduling part and specifically we
can create an extra VM also called surge
VM before draining the node and you can
see how disruption period actually
shortens and it equals now only the time
that it requires community to reschedule
your workload from node to node we call
this feature search upgrades we're going
to launch it in alpha this
you're welcome to use it but what
exactly it means for your workload well
I cannot look inside of your application
but what I can do is that I can create a
simple demo app that is a little bit
more sophisticated than a stateless
thing there is a state here there is a
storage that I read and write into on
each of the graphs the upper line is the
queries per second or requests per
second for reads and writes and the
lower line is the error rate so the
upper half of the graph is actually what
happens to the workload when we do the
regular upgrades as we do them right now
kela note let it come up you can see
that there are dips in the traffic as
well as spikes in the errors the lower
half of the screen shows you the same
app running on a similar cluster of
three notes but during the surge of
grades you can see that deep search more
shallow and also the errors are not that
frequent but even that kinda like proves
that there is only so much magic that we
can do for you in order to make sure
that your application is reliable there
is still it's not a silver bullet
solution there is still some things that
you can do as a customer and this is
where I would like to take my google hat
off and just talk about what were called
disruptions are and what you can do to
protect yourselves against it so let's
take a look at my simple app I'm running
three notes which is the default size on
Jukka as you know it's not too much it's
not a little it's exactly what you need
to run some sufficient workout as you
can guess from the names of those two
parts I'm running radius it's an
implementation detail
I'm not telling the you that you should
run radius just to show you that there
is some state and to make things a
little bit more interesting I actually
have a persistent volume connected to
that register
so what happens here the client attempts
the perform writes and reads and let's
take a look at the code so that I'm not
just telling you something all you need
to know is that I initiate the client I
have the connection to radius and then I
attempt a write and if it succeeds I
reported if it doesn't I also report it
and then I read and that's it that's all
I have in my simple demo app so let's
take a look at the logs so there's some
reason race happening when we upgrade a
node we take it down and that means that
we actually kill your pod right and that
means that at certain point your
application starts serving errors of
course kubernetes reschedule the pod and
the situation recovers however there is
a period during which you serve errors
if we delete the client itself as you
can guess it's going to be even worse
you will stop serving traffic altogether
so you have no connection to the
customer altogether what can you do to
amend that let's not talk about regice
for a second here it's talk only about
the client one of the obvious things to
do here is just increase the number of
replicas that you have and let's just
make sure that we know what is happening
behind the scenes
so we had one let's say three three is a
good number so we see that now
immediately we have three apps three
pods scheduled and running but what is
actually where they running well turns
out that they all got scheduled on three
different notes on two notes two of the
notes where the three replicas got
scheduled are the same which means that
when we attempt to upgrade that
particular note you will still lose
two-thirds of your capacity of your
serving capacity so that's still not
good enough what can we do to amend that
what we can do is that we can tell the
scheduler hey by the way I know what I'm
doing and try to schedule those
particular replicas on different nodes
which is to say we plan to use pod ante
affinity let's add that
you
and we can see that immediately the
scheduler obeyed our request and
rescheduled the pod so that we have them
evenly distributed across the nodes so
that we can rely on at least two-thirds
of the client capacity always be
available during an upgrade so if you
don't remember anything from this talk
today just take this back with you
redundancy redundancy is important there
are many things that we can do for you
at Google but you have to take care of
yourself by providing yourself a little
bit of slack what specifically it means
if you have no idea what you're doing
that's okay
just remember the simplest formula
possible that sre love and +1 just give
yourself some breathing room but not
only give it but also use it you can
think about your application as
different folder mains that you want to
separate and run separately of each
other so that if part of your
application fails the other one still
can survive and serve some traffic
however is that good enough if we have
redundancy let's take a look so I have
prepared a different cluster which is a
little bit more and what I have here is
I have many more nodes I have nine nodes
in total
I also have three replicas of a client
as we saw earlier I added them but here
I also have six replicas of redis which
are configured to be a cluster if you
don't know what the radius cluster is it
doesn't matter what you have to think
about it is there is enough redundancy
there are three masters three slaves and
they connected in such a way that if you
lose there's a certain threshold if you
lose certain capacity you're still good
to go
but is that good enough let's see so
let's say I was working on a script and
I just forgot what I was doing so I just
want to run it to see what was happening
turns out I was working on a script to
drain a cluster however I left at Midway
and as you can see I actually caused a
total outage I quadrant all the notes
and I also removed all the ports evicted
all the ports from those nodes
let me quickly restore that so that we
can continue with the demo so which
means that we don't see that we had
didn't save us in a matter of seconds I
created a total outage and that can be
you know a human error or a mistake an
honest mistake
what can you do to protect yourself
against that and again kubernetes
is such a huge universe that there are
many many mechanisms but the simplest
thing you can do is you can add the put
disruption budget and code disruption
budget is a place where you say okay
these are the parts that I want to
protect and this is the rule that I want
to apply to the particular deployment or
stateful set or whatever you have for
instance Mac's unavailable can be only
one at a time there should be only one
put unavailable or similarly just to
show of what poor disruption budget has
you can also specify mean available how
many at the time should be available in
contrary let's apply those to
so we'll not have those two in place and
we have actually our application
restored and running and you can see
that PDB says that there is allow
disruption of port number one for each
of those deployments that I have so what
happens if I will try to just drain
everything again well this is already it
looks like good news I have messages
coming back that cannot evict a pod and
that's because the scheduler knows that
I have a certain rules in place and so
how many replicas should be running at a
time and you can see that yes I managed
to can like get rid of one pod in each
state for set and deployment and I also
managed the card on the notes but there
is no total outage we're still serving
traffic we're still okay for the time
when we try to recover so redundancy is
not enough you have to put in place and
protection if you are extra paranoid and
that's right to be extra paranoid
additionally there will be no demo but
additionally you can also help us to
help you by providing a little bit more
detail of what exactly you're running in
your black box and specifically you can
use the readiness probe and the liveness
probe - things that I used during the
kubernetes lifecycle that help us
understand is your application ready to
receive traffic and that's readiness
probe or is your application healthy
enough and that's aliveness from if not
let's restart in case of a radius that I
was using those particular things would
be just pinging the various CLI to make
sure that the instances are available so
with those three in place let's take a
look what happened to the demo app that
I had this is just to remind you how the
graphs look before and this is after the
APIs tuned so even with the current
upgrade mode that we have when we have
to kill a VM at a time
you're still already doing much better
with serger braids you're
almost golden but there will be no magic
in this world so you will have
disruption at any point of upgrades you
just have to accept it as price for
staying up to date and just a couple of
words of things that you should not be
doing one of them is specified means max
unavailable zero or mean available
equals to the number of replicas that
you're running because for us is just a
hard stop we cannot do anything because
the scheduler will refuse to drain a
note where we have one of your pots
running similarly you should be careful
about the liveness Pro because if the
loudness probe that you define does not
sustain a load and it will fail that
means that kubernetes will think that
the application is unhealthy and
reschedule it which means just cascading
failure if you're really experiencing a
severe load in the same manner I
termination grace period should be
something meaningful it can be zero
which means that we don't wait
whatsoever or it cannot be ours when we
have to just wait hours and with that I
would like to hand over to Justin I'm
here from la blaw and you know we are
Canada's largest retailer and it's
interesting to think about that Canada
is like the second largest you know
North America second largest landmass
it's only like 33 million people that
live there and so it's it's crazy to
think that it's like 85% of Canadian
shop in one of our locations every week
right and so that's a whole lot of trust
that our country places in US and it's a
really deep customer relationship and so
as a result our mission is pretty big
right we want to help Canadians live
life well and so for me at la blaw
digital my goal is to do that in the
lens of cloud native and so I'm really
humbled to to work and run a team called
engineering productivity and and for us
our mission is to reduce toil increase
happiness and get [ __ ] done right and
and it's it's the confluence of trying
to have the philosophies of DevOps and
of sre and of shift left and thinking
about how we enable engineers to solve
problems rather than hiring people to
verify if engineers solve those problems
right it's all about enablement and what
we really love is that in kubernetes
we're able to bring that conversation
together and the great demos that you
just saw that manifest yamo whether it's
actually how we deploy the application
scale the application adding liveliness
and readiness checks you would have Sree
generating that you would have DevOps
engineers editing that heck you should
have QA x' or anyone in your
organization actually looking and
understanding what that is that's your
source of truth right everything is code
and so overall the fundamental goal we
have is to operate at the intersection
of innovation and stability and what's
funny is I was thinking about this today
law was actually a hundred-year-old
company and I think about you know what
we're doing in kubernetes and thinking
about managing load and resiliency and
there's this really interesting tidbit I
know from her Wikipedia page we actually
invented the shopping aisle in like the
late 1800s and before then if you look
at like old movies there was a dude
behind the counter and he would grab
your stuff and give it to you right like
the max number of customers you could
serve as one in a resilient you know a
redundancy factor of one if he didn't
make it to work like nothing could
happen and the idea of the shopping idea
right is is it's that innovation of what
if we could actually serve more
customers and they could serve
themselves and make their lives better
and it's interesting being in retail
where we have the ability to impact not
only technology but what's happening in
the real world with our customers right
and it's not always in the data center
that those wins are happening is it
sometimes actually in the physical world
and so it's just been really interesting
to see how that same message carries on
through a hundred years so specifically
you know what I really like to talk to
you about today it's a very thin sliver
of what we do but it's about how GK has
really made our lives easier in 2018 one
thing that was really great for us was
the first year that we had a Black
Friday and Cyber Monday where none of
our systems crashed and even more
impressive for us was that we actually
maintained our SLA for a response time
and error rate throughout and that's
just really thanks to Google and that
mission it's the first year we've been
running entirely natively and GCP and
we're really proud of that
Bushmen and so it's great to focus on
error rate it's great to focus on
response rate and just be up but for me
and my team like I said it's engineering
productivity it's about getting things
done faster it's about reducing toil
it's about increasing happiness and
something that's really really toil 'fl
is upgrades right coming from Canada's
artists retail or running I believe the
largest data center in the country we
have two of them a PR and a dr upgrades
are a nightmare right they take an
entire team of people a very concerted
effort to think about how are we keeping
our packages up-to-date our operating
seperating systems up-to-date and our
servers up-to-date and so when we saw
the ability to use the functionality of
auto upgrades we were there because we
didn't want that to have to be a burden
that our team took on and so auto
upgrades have three bane benefits right
security reliability and functionality
and a great example if you all know the
Runcie violation that recently came out
it's a really serious CV by the time we
knew about it
we were already safe alright and that's
thanks to the great work that the Google
team are doing to keep the Masters in
actually in that case it was container
OS didn't even have the flaw and there's
another one there was a privileged
escalation CV that happened late last
year and that was actually having those
Auto upgrades on before we found out
about it we were already safe and so
from a security perspective it seems
like a no-brainer but something that
Kate did a great job of highlighting is
that work disruption can be a really
serious issue right and so we love
automation we love magic
but sometimes later can be safer than
now and I'll give you a kind of a good
example as to why if I'm in retail when
I upgrade is actually really important
if we are in the middle of Black Friday
or if it's even a Thursday because
Thursday's when we launch our promotions
I probably don't want to run that risk
of having a disruption happen because in
the best case we get the really nice
graph the Kate showed in the worst case
that graphs a whole lot nastier
and so today right opting into Auto
upgrades I feel great toys reduced but I
don't have quite enough control
today google allow you to set a four
hour window of when they should do their
upgrades but there's a couple things
that doesn't account for unfortunately
one thing it doesn't account for is the
day of the week to do that upgrade and
for that that's important to us and the
second is the calendar year like
thinking ahead we know when our big
milestones are and for retail obviously
once again Black Friday and Cyber Monday
those two are gonna come up please don't
touch our infrastructure around these
times or if you're you know working in a
company that has code freezes right for
holidays or vacations where you don't
have staff on hand that's really
important so some of you might not be
opting into Auto upgrades because you
don't have that control we've taken the
risk and for us reducing the toilet
having to do it ourselves was worth the
potential risk of it going wrong and us
having to be there at an odd time and
then the other one is around how you
upgrade them right now it's an
all-or-nothing approach and when we do
it Google do it doesn't node by node
today and what we've noticed is that
we're running a multi-tenant multi
cluster and a multi regional cluster at
that at Loblaw one interesting thing is
we believe that all of our businesses
are good neighbors and that allows us to
invest in something we call soft
multi-tenancy right we don't have to
have the strict isolation because it's
an implicit trust between let's say Joe
Fresh which is our retailing clothing
brand and shoppers Drug Mart where we're
doing beauty products and pharmacy and
we actually might want to make that a
really strong connection because they
may have services that talk to each
other like their shared communal login
which is our PC ID application and so
for us Multi cluster has been really
important but when we do an upgrade
right when we're exposing that Auto
upgrade and that's going node by node
we're actually impacting a lot of our
businesses and so one feature that we've
really loved is this idea of node pools
and node pulls you can actually have it
so that an upgrade happens in a specific
node pool and so we definitely recommend
not just using the default node pool
right and whether your t-shirt sizing
small medium or large for certain
workloads or doing it per business that
kind of gives you an ability to break up
your upgrades and make sure they're safe
in one place before moving on
the second thing that we've seen is the
what are we upgrading right and for
those of you today like there's a
there's a lot of kubernetes versions
right and we it's moving extremely
quickly and we whether it's patch
whether it's major or whether it's minor
for us when we're Auto upgrading we feel
good about that we're getting new
security updates but we're not quite
sure what else is coming um and so I
feel like I'm sleeping safer at night
but I don't know what to tell my
engineers they now have access to and we
felt like we didn't really have enough
control at times to understand what
channel we're even on like that bleeding
edge of alpha versus beta versus stable
and so we're hoping that we can see some
more control in those areas but at the
same time from a Productivity
perspective we're really thankful that
we can upgrade very quickly and so
overall you know later can sometimes be
safer than now you know I would suggest
that everyone that cares about these
upgrades and their own sanity
get off the manual training into Auto
and by doing so get the feedback to
Google for how automatic upgrades can be
made better and I think overall we will
be in a better place if we're focused on
engineering as a retailer we want to
sell groceries I really don't want to be
in the business of managing operating
systems managing upgrades and having to
staff people for that and at the end of
the day the people that we staff to do
that I don't know if anyone was born
with the idea that like my big dream in
life is to upgrade operating systems
like you know operations engineers like
we have big ideas and big dreams and
when I look about the amazing features
that Kate showing off that's what we
want our engineers to be doing right so
I think we should aim higher in that
regard for the type of work we're doing
and the impact that we're having in our
organizations so you know overall we're
really excited by these new features
that are coming out
we're heavily invested in this from the
LA blood digital side and I'll hand it
back to Kobe to see what's coming next
then
[Applause]
so so far we spoke about challenges we
we saw some amazing demos and we heard
from Justin about their experience next
I'm excited to share with you some of
the new capabilities we are working on
to actually provide you with even more
control and flexibility we'll be
focusing on three areas reduce risk
control disruption and manage risk let's
talk about the first one how you can
reduce risk and Kate mentioned it before
so we are actually changing the way we
will be upgrading nodes in clusters
managed by gke right now the way we
upgrade nodes is at a time of the
upgrade we'll go one node after the
other and we'll remove that node and
bring a new one with the new version
that's obviously slightly disruptive for
customers and we are changing that
process with the surge upgrade so with
surge upgrade will actually create a new
node first and then we'll gracefully
drain the old one and and at that time
we'll remove the old node what that
gives you is a few things one it allows
us to secure resources before we even
start upgrades because we create that
node before we take all take the old one
down the second thing is we ensure
successful completion of the node
upgrade we protect your customer your
capacity right so at any given point of
time you have the number of nodes you
expect to have even during upgrades and
that in turn reduce disruption and
reduce downtime Justin mentioned the
maintenance windows support we have
today so yes you can create maintenance
windows and we will respect that
basically the feature we have right now
supports four hours maintenance windows
in any given day so obviously there's
less flexibility right now next we are
actually going to enhance the
maintenance windows capabilities to
support different use cases like the use
case that justin mentioned so let's say
you prefer to avoid upgrades during
weekends because you are a gaming
company and most of the traffic is
in through the weekends you'll be able
to do that with the enhancement and and
supposed maintenance window support if
you are a retailer and you are trying to
avoid completely any maintenance events
during Black Friday Cyber Monday you
will be able to specify the range of
dates and will respect that and avoid
the upgrades during those times and then
lastly you know about upcoming upgrade
but you just need more time
you need more time prepare or you have
some internal challenges that you're
facing you'll be able to postpone or
snooze an upgrade for a short period of
time that gives you more flexibility in
controlling disruption the other thing
the other way to control disruption is
really our release notes and
transparency is really key for us in the
release notes you get much more
information than just the changelog
you'll get information about the
upcoming release schedule they released
that we are duplicating the the releases
that we are going to make available and
the other thing is we have a four days
rollout policy in Jiki so we roll out
new version in different regions during
four days you can actually see that
schedule in the release notes so we are
publishing what version is coming first
in which region and you can actually
plan your upgrade accordingly let's talk
about managing risk we spoke about ways
to manage risk and I think PDB or por
disruption budget is super-important
capability that we support today
especially if you have a stateful
application but in order to support your
risk mitigation canary cluster will
allow you to create a cluster and
designated for canary or staging
environment that in turn will indicate
to us that we should roll out new
versions to those canary cluster before
we roll them out to your production
clusters so there will be kind of a
mapping between your canary clusters and
your production clusters so we'll roll
out new version will give you enough
time to run your automate tests to get
some confidence and when you greenlight
the version we'll continue rolling out
the upgrades to production as well in
another exciting feature in q2
is released channels we spoke about the
amount of versions we support and it's
really overwhelming and we are trying to
make it easier for customer and move
away from that structure of supporting
many many versions to supporting three
channels we are thinking right now about
rapid regular and stable so if you want
to get early access to the latest and
greatest bleeding-edge version of
kubernetes you probably want to be on
the rapid channel and let's say you have
a testing environment you will be able
to say hey this is my testing clusters
and I want to subscribe this cluster to
the rapid Channel will make sure to roll
out new bleeding-edge versions in that
specific cluster same thing with regular
and stable regular will give you the
default version like the one we have
today available in the fleet and stable
you will probably get less features but
it will be more stable in terms of
Moore's it the version accumulate more
soap time and we have more test coverage
for that specific channel just a quick
example of how this may look like from a
command line perspective so you can
create a new cluster and subscribe it to
the rapid Channel so we spoke about
different and many great features and I
just want to take a moment to kind of
bring it all together our goal is is to
keep your cluster up and running and and
deliver a non-disruptive experience even
during upgrades then visibility is key
for us as I mentioned before we want to
make sure that you understand our
product life cycle and you can plan
accordingly we have to provide a so free
manage kubernetes service so you can
focus on what you care about and your
core business if you are interested in
any one of the feature that I mentioned
today please follow this link and you
can sign up and and share with us your
interest in joining the alpha program
for one of these features
[Music]